we saw Pixar's adaptation of Netflix is
bright and the sequel to year one
starring Jack Black and Michael Cera
very impressive stuff oh yeah Disney's
knocking it out the park here all jokes
aside we saw on word the latest film
from Pixar starring star-lord and
spider-man I was gonna say yeah I wasn't
the guy from spies in disguise yeah so
this takes place in a world where in the
past it was all full of magic so you
have like pixie fairies orcs and all
that and they still exist now but they
become quite modernized so they
forgotten all about magic and this movie
focuses on two brothers Tom Holland is
the main character a guy named Ian and
his brother is Chris Pratt a guy named
barley barley lives in a world where
he's like obsessed with games like
Dungeons and Dragons essentially so he
knows all about magic and believes it
ought to be real and then one day on
Ian's 16th birthday the brothers are
gifted a staff from their deceased
father which magically brings their
father back to life but only halfway the
bottom half so they have 24 hours to
figure out how to bring back the rest of
the dab which put some on an adventure
overcoming fears and insecurities
brotherly bond roadtrip bringing the
magic back into their lives we saw this
on 4dx regal Ellie live 40x and it was
pretty incredible they really made this
an experience when you see the trailers
like how much 40 X and you get out of
this they managed to make it so 40 X is
such a road trip of a movie and it's so
calculated in every movement they had
everything rain mist effects the right
kind of motion depending on what the
motion of the characters were it was
like being on a ride at Universal
Studios this time around and a great
immersive way I got a set and not to
mention one of my very favorite 4dx
specific jokes ever in the theater is
their conditioning man just got me
varley's air conditioner just so strong
they turned the air up to like a hundred
percent in the theater and and and that
got a good left
okay my experience with this movie the
first 20 minutes of it I was really
hesitant I did not think I would
ultimately enjoy it the jokes were not
really landing for me like the animation
immediately is beautiful it's kind of
got this interesting mix because so much
of the environment and objects look so
real and then you got all these like
cartoony characters which they do a
great job at blending in and creating
these shadow outlines of them so that
way they feel naturally blended in with
the environment but it was always so
striking so the animation from beginning
to him was awesome but the first 20
minutes it seemed like like a Disney
Channel movie to me for some reason but
honestly once the adventure kicks in
when they get on the road I really
started to enjoy it I started to get a
lot of laughs from it and the last half
of this movie really spoke to me a lot
like I was starting to feel the Wonder I
was really starting to feel the magic I
was moved to tears maybe like two or
three times especially towards the
finale it's got a great message a
chemistry between Tom Hall and Chris
Pratt is awesome cuz Chris Pratt's
character kind of has a Jack Black thing
about him you and I both were flashing
to Jack Black during the film his
character is annoying at first and he's
supposed to be though he said but they
call him a screw-up and he's supposed to
be annoying but by the end of the movie
you love the guy like I really do and I
gotta say like I know that some people
are kind of lukewarm on this this is a
guy who created monsters University and
a lot of people who saw monsters
University had like a yeah it was cool
kind of feeling with this movie and for
me I think on a personal level just hits
me a lot more I have an older brother I
really identify with it Tom Holland
character my older brother did this
exact same thing with me the whole time
whole time my brother is exactly this
guy jab Iike way follow him he's such a
screw-up in a failure
get off your ass yeah be something with
your life and then also like we both
lost our father a few years ago that
brought us closer together so there's so
much in here that I connect with on a
much more personal level than maybe most
people what started off as a I don't
know about this - oh I'm liking it
eventually
- I do love this movie so yeah this
movie really left an impact on me yeah I
think this was a really fun thoughtful
movie for Pixar Disney I mean it is a
Pixar Disney movie and and to me what
that combination has started to mean is
that we'll get kind of a straightforward
and more focused on being family
accessible kind of movie that has some
above-average nuance and heart applied
to it and yeah I mean I feel like in a
lot of ways this is a traditional
animated movie it's not a Shrek knockoff
which I appreciate it and I've seen at
least one capsule or if you claimed it
to be it this is almost like if the
universe of Shrek literally pushed on
into the present day so I can see that
parallel but yeah I thought what the
story was about and the fact that it is
brotherly bonding lost the relationship
between fathers and sons and whatnot
everything at the core of it and and the
moments were it truly saying were pretty
beautiful and everything else I had a
similar experience to you about the
first third of the movie I wasn't that
moved especially in one particular
direction and then in the middle part I
started to get more with it kind of
hidden out and then by the last third I
was really enjoying myself really in for
the adventure in the imagination and the
ride and the heartfelt qualities so
while this isn't a favorite of mine from
Pixar I think there's definitely a lot
to appreciate to me it's more in that
sort of like good dinosaur tier where
I'm like it was really well made it's
really beautiful to look at it
definitely has some really touching
moments definitely I think a great movie
for everyone in the family there'll be
something for everyone so yeah it
doesn't seem quite as truly and honestly
Pixar as like soul looks like it it
probably be feel like Pixar exists now
on kind of a one for us one for them
kind of model but even if this is one of
them more straightforward family
accessible movies I still think it's a
cut above for its nuances yeah yeah I'd
say so uh you got some cool female
characters in here too you got their mom
played by Julia louis-dreyfus who is
she's pretty funny she's fine and
Octavia Spencer played this character
called the manticore who I got a big
kick out of throughout I think the
finale is honestly some really powerful
stuff there are some moments in there in
just terms of animation and high stakes
that I won't spoil for you guys when it
was going down I was so swept up in it I
was so involved in the character arcs
the animation of a lot of the acts
Chinn sequences have me just going whoa
that looks freaking awesome that was
amazing I really do think that just the
biggest issue this movie has is the
first act it kind of just hit me right
now as to maybe why that is the case and
that's because you kind of have this
heavy theme here of loss you have this
main character Ian who has all these
insecurities that have developed because
he doesn't feel like he had his father
in his life and he still wants to
somehow connect and live up to this
image that has been recently introduced
to him of who his father was someone who
is the exact opposite of him and I think
where movies like up for example work so
well is because they're not trying to be
a comedy the first like 20 minutes yeah
they're willing to let you sink into the
internal drama conflicts the struggles
heart brokenness of these characters in
the beginning of the film and then the
comedy does come in and it's really
funny but the movie here I felt like
they didn't want to lead with that so
they pushed a lot of comedy in here that
just didn't work in the first half but
eventually I got I'll say there's some
stuff that had me just cracking up it's
like the last half of this time I
genuinely loved so I think it's worth
checking out especially the theaters for
the animation I can totally see why
people are just kind of like yeah it's
fine
I can respect that but for myself and I
think my brother I haven't talked to my
brother about this but I think he loved
it - yeah I think ears to hear you guys
review it yeah I think he also really
loved this movie and it was one of those
things where when it was done it did
make me appreciate my brother more I
called him and told in the go vote yeah
the day we watch this was on Super
Tuesday also - I do really appreciate
about this movie that there are some
really really great moments of just
physical animation going back to the
point about the comedy there were almost
times were when the movie was at its
quietest I was enjoying it the most
because that's where the very physical
and the Moore's kind of sophisticated
animation things come out there's a
really touching back and forth bit that
just involves a toe tap little things
like that I think are especially
beautiful about this movie yeah it's
like the first half the dialogue driven
comedy wasn't so funny but when there
was like physicality involved especially
when the animation and the editing
working again
that really accentuated a lot of it I
just think the the themes of like
handling grief and the theme to uh
without spoiling anything of being able
to appreciate what you have now truly
and seeing that sometimes what you're
looking for you've had your whole life
is such an important message for kids
and adults as well it's something that
heavily resonates with me on a daily
basis yeah go check it out guys go check
it out I think I think it's well worth
the watch I'm watching a 40 X if you can
because this is some of the best work
they've done composing everything that
forty X has to offer you alright guys
did you see onward where would you rank
it in the Pixar films leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
about like and notify whatever got a
youtube video up and last but not least
let's end this with a path called Orion
see pineco so you'd fit in in the world
of onward you could slay something now
kids if you're watching this review you
shouldn't be our videos are not made for
you but I wrote you a poem called Orion
since you didn't get one last month his
name is Cal Dorian a handsome Native
American destined to be a praise writer
it's almost Shakespearean adapt his
books into movies
I'll buy his collection make sure its
criterion hails from the land of
Colorado a handsome man an impressive
and intimidating bravado favorite comic
character is Jean Grey read my mind cul
de rien
please pay to stay at our patreon page
because I love the way you and I relay
never want to say vamoose to mr. Pinnock
coos feel free to let loose and on my
chest you can drop a deuce if it's the
best excuse for this dynamic to never
conform to recluse wow wow I just
learned something about the both of you
queue it up